and Sajid Javid was appointed Home
Secretary after the Windrush scandal it
was a breath of fresh air
he was an effective business secretary
and as community secretary openly
admitted government failures over
Grenfell he's also the son of a
Pakistani bus driver at a time when
Islamophobia is rising and one of the
biggest threats to our national security
is Islamist terrorism here was a clear
sign from mrs. May that Britain didn't
tarnish all those from an Islamic
background with the same brush so you
can imagine my shock and dismay when
this week
Sajid Javid himself tweeted a blanket
statement about aged about the Asian
community in relation to the
huddersfield grooming gangs
we all accept these horrific crimes were
racially motivated but Javed's tweet was
so badly worded I had to read it twice
to make sure I was seeing right
sadly just as internalized misogyny is
real so is internalized racism sometimes
when people from discriminated
backgrounds are in positions of power
they can feel the need to prove
themselves in this way
Sajid Javid of all people should know
better in these troubling times he
should be trying to bring us together
not so further division before before I
come back we should read the tweet out
that causes so much attention what's
Adam Javed said was these sick Asian
pedophiles are finally facing justice I
want to commend the bravery of the
victims for too long they were ignored
not on my watch there will be no no-go
areas okay so what he said there he
called these monsters he called them
sick and he called them Asian and he
called them pedophiles and he's right on
every cow their ethnicity was
intrinsically linked to what they did
their ethnicity is what stopped gangs in
Rother Rochdale Telford being caught for
more than a decade it meant that
thousands of young girls were raped
drugged girls as young as 11 raped and
drugged by gangs of Pakistani grooving
gangs now this is not this is not racist
to say that it's just because if we say
it's racist to point out their ethnicity
that means
betray these girls yet again these girls
were betrayed by the police by local
authorities by councils by social
services because they were Asian and
they didn't want to be accused of racism
but and go after these guys but and I'll
let you come back at me but the quillion
thing time produced a report this week
not this week recently that said 84
percent of people convicted for child
grooming crimes were Asian and another
of 264 crimes 222 or committed by Agent
J Jun we have to talk about that we have
to talk about the reasons why and then I
should have I promise that I'll you the
floor the people they targeted the girls
they targeted were mainly white I said
this yes they're mainly white so if
we're if we're talking about the group
of people who were targeted because they
were white why can't we talk about the
ethnicity of the people who were
targeting them I'll come back on that
well first of all can I say Nick and I
were with the Home Secretary yesterday
and I actually told him I would be
discussing his tweet and that I was
completely against it and he actually
said go for it I look forward to what I
suggest you were arrested there are a
couple of things here I think the the
whole point is we know that these
terrible acts were racially motivated my
issue with sadhu Javed's quote is how he
worded it because you can you can still
reference the fact that these attacks
were racially motivated without it being
a blanket statement that involves
interception to keep a beautiful job I
totally agree with what David Lammy had
to say on this and and can I bring that
up because his quote on this I think was
spot-on
he said by fiddling out Asians
he not only panders to the far-right but
increases the risk of violence and abuse
against minorities across the country
whatever the underlying motives of the
offenders involved pedophilia is an
abhorrent crime that affects all
communities let me finish it does not
service it doesn't it does no service to
the victims of this evil to pin the
blame on anyone groove it's not singling
our agents 84% of child grooming crabs
will committed by agent
George's pedophile rings are committed
by white people we would never the
majority ad would you put it in that way
the issue I mean I think he's tweeting
you can make up your mind with it it's
offensive motion but there is an issue
here in town after town after town when
we have seen these these of these are
basically men of Pakistan the other
that's the key men was once a Asian you
could be Japanese sure serious piece of
research or an inquiry into were these
connected they all just happen I have no
idea it's right to say that it's them
it's the majority who are of Pakistan
you know there are other they're Somalis
were involved in the Bristol incidents
let's turn I thought that Allison
Pearson and it's important that we bring
in a woman who is also a mom the
journalist and author says this I'm
afraid the facts are as plain as they
are unpalatable certain male members of
one community still steeped in notions
of female chastity honor and shame
somehow feel it's okay to help
themselves to vulnerable girls in the
majority community which prizes neither
chastity nor honor and is to all intents
and purposes shameless if and to pick up
on Carol's point if and he's absolutely
right it probably needed the word mostly
Pakistani in there somewhere but if you
don't acknowledge those facts and I know
you would never want this you run the
risk of another Rotherham or another
rock style or another topic I am NOT
saying that we don't acknowledge it I am
just saying the way he worded this tweet
was so clumsy and actually it was a dog
whistle to the right and I think and I'm
sorry no no let me finish and I think
actually back to my point about
internalized racism sometimes what
happens in the same way you can have
women in positions of power and their
harsher on other women than a man would
be I actually think sometimes when you
have somebody from a discriminated group
in a position of power they feel they
need to prove that there will be extra
harsh when it's from a group that comes
from the same ethnic group as themselves
sorry Michelle I just find this
absolutely staggering because all no
again I don't agree with you know I know
I don't agree with you and I find it
staggering that we are still
contemplating whether describing these
perpetrators as Asian is offensive or
not it's a fact whether it's offend
whether people take offense well there's
no majority practices a big it is
because a lot of people and you don't
use blanket terms I would have said
majority I would have said racially
motivated attack my point is that people
disgusted by the likes of Tommy Robinson
they people think it's disgraceful at
people like he exists and I argue back
and what I say to that is the reason why
people like Tommy Robinson are getting
more and more momentum is because there
is a massive sense that if people try to
point out what factually correct things
they are suppressed because of political
political correctness and what I'm
saying is that I know it might not be
your point but my point is is linked and
what I'm saying is that at the end of
the day you have to be able to talk
about what situations as they stand
without suppressing thing is for fear of
causing offence or political correctness
because when you don't what happens is
like city can hear when he's talking
about the phrase that Sajid Chavez he's
talking about
oh it's clear that conservative
politicians think that the way to
succeed is by playing to the far right
it's not far right what do identify what
do you think it's about right and I
think it no I think it's pandering I
think it's pandering to a certain
section of society I would never do that
you know but I think this and I'm we
were with him yesterday but I do think
that Sajid Javid like many politicians
is somebody who is another danger that
because we haven't accepted this I mean
and looked at it seriously and done the
proper research and try to understand
what's happening because of that
actually what you do is you encourage
the far-right you encourage the people
who might support them because they
think no one is
my point is I completely accept it and I
completely totally acknowledged that
these crimes were racially motivated
they were going for girls that were
white they were not going for girls from
the pack one of these girls I think it's
really important I used to buy you gifts
give you cigarettes alcohol cannabis and
then I would have in a relationship
prove one of them and then it's like you
just start getting passed around to the
friends and stuff and some days you're
waking up can you don't even know how
you ended up in certain places you can't
remember what happens here it's like the
older ones pass it down to the younger
generation so history will just keep on
repeating itself as long as that happens
you don't think there's been any change
at all no I don't think it has that
concerns me it makes me it makes me sick
to my stomach
and all I want to say is a highlight of
Kent is not far right yet it's a point
out were common obvious facts and it's
not far right to point out the SF Nissa
T of a group of people if that is the
common thing that people feel is an
aggravating factor as to why they're
committing those crimes just to one add
to that what I'm saying is when it is
done by somebody who is white we add the
distinction we would say of white
supremacist or whatever we wouldn't say
all white people